[Music]
all right welcome everybody all right
bullet roll time yeah we're going to get
e Caro in the first game here we
go
oh
right
go do
go
yeah
um like this something takes
takes I'm
cel
C8
now
[Music]
um
everything
this is
sum I can't stand
this I don't know if you guys hear that
it's
ridiculous
the mic is
correct no the gardeners are are
outside we it's like
yeah Arena's pretty dangerous actually o
to establish
night
[Music]
file that was a
bad
[Music]
Ary um6 for
instance
oh this is thing
this
um I can take
maybe
um that looks bad move you can actually
take that
Wonder
um I think I just won cuz Bishop B5 is
coming okay
sardo is not really a
move
this is completely winning it's just got
to be so
[Music]
fun back here oh crap it can
take oh but mate
God I didn't see that you could even
take that
night thank you poers 27 for the prime
okay Pina
Shala
[Music]
um here
something centralized
establish here
maybe I think I can just go for the P
actually
um here
wi oh my God what is this Magnus is
playing uh oh that's not good Magnus is
playing
also Magnus joined a little late
fashionably late as they say Magnus the
kind of guy who always comes last to the
party
and everybody's waiting and oh okay
Magnus is here now the party can
[Music]
begin
okay this is not good what am I
[Music]
doing
I almost want to take here and go
here no that was
crappy oh my gosh what am I
doing I'm still better
somehow yeah I'm much better
here now I'm completely
winning
let's go be careful not to blunder any
kind of lobster pincer lolli's mate I
think the simple Knight G5 is good
enough or not or did I blunder take
check go
back okay so he wants to take so we go
up and now he wants to move to the
side
up
game goo are
[Applause]
gay
um
okay to figure out to move
here threatening e I'm threatening a
bunch of
stuff
I
Caro let's brush
him
[Music]
bad
I don't have to do
anything oh now I can take
crap yeah I choke that
one
maybe no it's just
lost yeah I forgot what why you played
F6
five is interesting but very
risky D4
maybe D6 at
100 oh but I can maybe take
here
[Music]
don't understand
this oh Bishop H6 a okay but
here oh
no man that was just very
unlucky
I just I just completely ignored all the
threats clearly winning need to make one
more prophylactic
move
girl is very
[Music]
resilient I need to get back on a
stre there we
go quick one there okay car is going to
pass me momentarily and Magnus they're
they're on my
tail another easy
game or not I played Bishop
G4 your goo is so unpleasant to play the
guy just always lunges at your king and
sometimes it
works
[Music]
can take
care by the time she calculates it
that's the thing I'm going have
time he's completely
lost do another
win
yeah he car just passed me and Magnus
did
too can't you B oh Queen C7 my
[Music]
gosh away with
this
huh unreal have to go
[Music]
E3 yeah I win the
queen sloppy
game
[Music]
can I just grab this
guy
wa F5 doesn't really
work
[Music]
stuck
um
[Music]
oh
Oh Oh I thought it was stalemate oh man
how did I lose that I was just totally
winning now we're playing
Magnus
frustrating I was I thought I was stal I
didn't see had a pawn
left and I just lost that the
opening no it's the typical at the car
we just find the only way to live wait
no I didn't L that the opening I this
now I'm
winning but it doesn't matter what the
evaluation is against
these always going to find a
[Music]
way a I'm so sloppy today
okay
was oh no I oh
man okay oh
no man and I'm just not getting lucky
right
now we not fakeing is
[Music]
over
quickly
very tough these guys are just they
never
die freaking die they're like me but in
even better version of
[Music]
me m
everyone's going for my king
[Music]
today in trouble
now he's got to go
B4 he's not seeing by the okay just
wonderers
everything okay resign
man not
resin okay now I caught hikaro and I got
to keep winning going to be a pretty
much a log Jam at the top I'm going to
have to beat hikaro Magnus a few times I
can't just beat everybody else and like
loose to them
me it's just so hard when you sense that
you're winning just fingers turn into
thumbs it's
unreal psychological influence that they
exert is just
[Music]
ridiculous these
systems
[Music]
this guy's very very very
dangerous anybody from Iran is already
going to be like 200 points
[Music]
underrated I need to get lucky in that
car and Magnus have to play each other
okay maybe we can take and go Knight D5
yeah that was a
mistake how do we win this
just why did I do that okay but I can go
back to
B6 yeah
G4 make
complicated
[Music]
there yeah know this blender and he
loses josam also passed me but now I
passed
everybody
y
[Music]
alsoa obviously we're not going for a
draw here how do I play this
[Music]
though yeah this is not good
actually oh
F4
[Music]
work neck or both
first
yeah it's going to go Knight H5 I
think yeah but it's turning
rage
oh yeah
[Music]
just not lucky
today
yeah Knight B5 I forgot to play a
six forgot to play a six no I'm
lost
St
[Music]
there we
go Karo and bording are pulling away so
I got to start
winning and Magnus too
Jesus a brutal
one
[Music]
is
I know if this works we'll
[Music]
see
oh my
gosh
draw
okay but this is not enough I have to
start
winning yeah everybody finished Qatar
and now it's like the strongest bullet
bra of
time okay just
win problem is Tak a lot I need a couple
fast ones I need to build up like a 7A
game winning streak that'll give me a
chance to reclaim first it's only like
14 points it's not a lot bik's on a 13
game winning streak it's crazy who is he
playing how is he not getting anybody
Magnus Dang or is he beating all of them
she never like
resigns there we go Magness again what
is
this
[Music]
a
I
unbelievable just
unreal I mean it's just crazy these guys
just don't go
down and I found the only
way
[Music]
you
for
under this
to I
did
okay I'm going to flag
him mag this games are really tilt
[Music]
okay quick wi there that's what I needed
I can pass bord against second car is
not come on got to get some wins against
him
[Music]
is
really
work now
is
I broke aat
trick I mean I again I was definitely a
win there but I didn't have
time everybody's playing the grand free
attack
oh my gosh this
suck
oh it's a mouse slip he meant to play
Queen C4 he offered me a draw yeah my
ass okay there we go good good stuff
stuff okay now I just need a streak
that's all I need I can get into first I
just need a
strak stop losing the hiar
Magnus
yeah this one
[Music]
okay just simply off today it just
happens but today is one of those days
it's all right try to get at least
third
she's
good
[Music]
no but come on I can't lose this game
you
serious okay she should not have done
that
I'm I'm going to
flager got want M
here got got her there
flag now your car is in first again okay
good
pairing
appearing
quickly hoping to get a quick
cheese
all right there we go relatively quick
win and fitos
okay
a winable
game go is super
solid
[Music]
e
I don't know if the upon end game is
drawn or
what
[Music]
this
line not sure where I'm
going
just trying to put some
pressure want
seven 94 isn't doing
anything
oh no going do
that
got him
there oh
man
I'm go
B5
no that was
bad yeah I'm
losing
no
okay
[Music]
yeah should be winning
here
okay Sor was
bad
okay here and
here why is there no win here
let see the
win taking
stuff May threatened take
here Mar arid
[Music]
again E5 I'm just going to cat cast go
for
mate okay I think I take this should be
good okay so now just going to go back
for
now
I'm going to win this one but'll take
some time yeah she
resigns Andrew won like 17 games in that
span AR chest mate okay this
guy Prett be dangerous
he going to go Queen side let's just go
[Music]
B4
oh should be
[Music]
seven and this guy is also like
Magnus okay so let's go let's go
back keep the pressure up know that was
terrible
[Music]
move
okay I'm losing now but I'm hoping he
makes a mistake cuz I'm threatening I
have tons of
threats maybe it's not even
losing maybe it's not even losing ooh
Queen A6 is also
threat yeah there's too many M
threats penguin passed me even though
I've been winning all this
time okay damoo three
[Music]
resign dude resign resign resign come on
there we
[Music]
go
okay
oh
yes our
query
need to be a little bit more careful I'm
being very sloppy
here five
maybe I maybe just now let just put
here Hing it blunders
something
Wonder okay that was a tough
game okay I canect actually pass the
Caro if I win a bunch of
games plundered all his pieces and let's
see if I can go a quick
resign
[Music]
nope no I'm not going to get a resign
that's the
problem
okay until now okay another
win okay V chest it's a winnable
game this is still
the
designs we win
again
okay let's go
[Music]
here
unfortunately
I'm trying to play really really quickly
here but these guys
are guys are dangerous thank you chz
Diva good to see you thank you for the
five Subs
appreciate yeah actually messed this up
pretty
badly try to flag him in in an end
game
nice should we
[Music]
losing okay here here
oh
and have to flag
him flag
him that was a mistake
though see
that and I'm going to
win
[Music]
but that was
disturbing that took a long
[Music]
time okay pan catch okay I'm getting
some easy pairings
here I have to win quickly
[Music]
also
the
duck what the
duck that's a free
piece and I think you're actually
supposed to take
here it takes
here back
oh CH okay that's
lost
ni
why did I do
this
come on resign
man we
go that's
on I
up I'm still winning though I
think yeah but now he's going to Castle
and it's going to be really
scary
or
resign man you're down a
queen Bo a dangerous
player um just go like
this
I
blundered one those
Gam
m
blockade I think
yeah no Oho
I almost lost that okay now I'm going to
draw okay he played well can I do he
played a good
[Music]
game I blended my Pawn at the end there
notice have taken
it
I'm just going to go for mate
here okay take
I um um what's going on
here how is he figuring this out so
fast
Shen this guy's pretty dangerous
actually
I'm going to try to
Counterattack
C3 C3 the heck is happening
here
just try to get the Queens off and flag
him obviously one of those players just
always going to keep the Queens on the
board get the hell out of
there
got him
there wow Andrew's C catching me even
though I won like all my games
[Music]
Andre to put
Caro
it
looks oh no he found it of
course found it
[Music]
ah okay he's going to repeat no I'm not
going to
[Music]
repeat wait I could have repeated and I
just started to lose instead
[Music]
oh it worked oh my gosh it worked it
worked that's what you get for repeating
that's what you get for trying to repeat
up a piece oh that was one of the best
bullet bra moments let's
go you freaking
[Music]
worked okay it doesn't actually do
anything cuz in the span that I won that
one game Andrew won 6,000
[Music]
okay okay it's just freaking
develop
[Music]
qu Legend unknown oh this guy don't like
playing this
guy
um
yeah
yeah looks like your car is pulling away
sadly
doing my
best binol is so
underrated
guy outplays me literally every time we
play now what was
that oh that wasn't stupid
am I
doing lose to Bolis
girl okay blenders is Rook that
helps go Belo
Alex God why is everybody who
recommended this in their freaking chest
full course everybody is playing this
now it's weird this this this A4 line
everybody's playing it wonder where who
recommended
it um here in
sec
[Music]
okay slow Back
Fighter I'm breathing down iar's neck
but
okay that's a free Queen for
that
[Music]
Arena
can I take
on2 yeah I
can little risky
though I'm getting
mated
cancer on B6 now trade
Queens was kind of getting mated there
but
now I should be able to
win no
threats oh my
gosh oh no
oh major
Panic major Panic big big big big big
Panic holy that was
close Caro okay have to win this
[Music]
one I have one a pce
that's like literally the first thing I
do is
[Music]
blender not sure why I did that but
great
okay I have Queen G3 doesn't do anything
though and it still doesn't do
anything
I
truly insane that might have been made
somewhere but I don't think there
was look likey car is going to get first
I fought
well okay I got to win a couple here
quickly to get back on the
streak
all right played it
well
but never deliver critical moment I got
to low on time it's fine I just got to
keep keep Penguin at
Bay okay good
pairing going very quickly
here can take a lot of
risks
one or
anything until
now Unstoppable thread of 96 family fork
okay please just
resign it takes I'm going to bank on
this am i blundering m or
something no I'm not the che
thing there
okay car Demitri good pairing got to go
after
him I'm just going to go for it I mean I
just need to like go for M every
game
[Music]
yeah car is in good form after but
typical for this guy to do this just
faking resign man you have no chances
girl I'm Ping On
Jack's going let his time run out
really I don't even really care he cars
He cars He car is Unstoppable but just
got to keep keep winning to keep Penguin
at Bay okay H Waffa good
paing
[Music]
o
uhoh
CL here I don't like playing this guy
actually at
all knows everything and plays very
accurately
um
no why am I
freezing see always
have
I don't get this
guy I'm to play for a very risky
move
oh no why did I do
that I knew I was going to lose I just
knew
it
more
no it's just a computer it's
insane and hi car also oh man I could
have actually caught him terrible
faing I don't get that guy he always
outplays
me
should resign yeah resign still oh no
another another genius another genius he
seems
tilted another
genius local
danc get that
up
it's going to flag
him
okay than keep psycho
monkey is it waiting to par me against
Saro or
something no it's paring it's old week
GM hard
spe
I don't know why I'm playing so badly
right
now was sort of a
blunder
um
St
[Music]
he's not going to make 50
moves God Andrew keeps breathing down my
neck
on yeah he's quite fast I
see
um
wait wait that's a bad move for
sure
[Music]
um know
play terrible
mod
[Music]
got him there oh Andrew one again and so
did
I and Andrew one again oh now I'm
playing
him
knew
[Music]
yes yes we stopped his streak and beat
him okay this
guy
I'm still I still have a chance to catch
aaro not
entirely not entirely
impossible oh you saw
it this guy is like super
Sharp
deserves
in ring R just seven huge
threat oh Queen D1 but
look okay we get that one
[Music]
ver
D can take
[Music]
D6
I really don't know what I'm
doing
how does he stop Pawn
now he can't I queen
before I want design
now there we
go
I'll T her
again
okay he wants queen B6 so I okay just
here okay
here
here wait check and check and I
win okay trainer I can actually catch
Yaro
I'm just trying to win really really
fast here
oh no no no no I Mouse slipped that oh
my gosh oh
no oh I Mouse slip the queen now I got
to
focus I'm still going to win but that's
frustrating okay here the the emphasis
is just on winning it's not on oh my God
what am I doing choking this
game stupid
M I'm just milking his clock
down no
mates okay we got
him if it was anybody higher rated that
was over
you got
excellent
slide Edge in the end
game
yeah the problem is take a
while gosh why am I why am might play
this
all right girl
resign go oh he car won two in the span
that I won that one and of course I get
wonderful
time I get really bad pairings usually
at the end of
tournaments
how did you car win two games in this
span that I won that one
I anyways it's time to dwell on
it
[Music]
I
h
is
[Music]
designed it's
good come on just give me someone easy
stop wait Caro okay beat him sprad all
the
marbles
I'm just joking this got get the tactics
[Music]
going yeah that was just a bad
game
still have a shot but I'm going to have
to get some
WIS and the way it's going I'm not going
to
[Music]
should
be see a thread for him oh and I
bled and I do have a draw to go
one I have a
draw I'm a choice though
yeah oh he goes for it only
on this guy's in an engine I don't know
what to say okay looks like we're going
to get
second
[Music]
I I need people to resign
instantly it's not going to happen
terrible terrible game to terrible
clutch game okay quick win there I still
have a minor chance of hearo loses but
I'm going to do my
best just got to win really quickly
here oh that I was
hinging I didn't see
it just going for
me I need I need I need people to resign
when they lost I once
said there's no
mate where's the
M okay I still have a chance I still
have a chance else
uh quickly
quickly
my problem is I'm getting crushed
yes the trainer okay
quickly
W he's too slow usually this is a good
pairing but oh Queen free Queen resign
resign resign resign
resign I guess I beat him up a queen so
this is
ridiculous one
mate oh hikaro lost his streak wait I'm
not pressing next game until he gets a
game okay there we
go I'm bojn
again no no oh my gosh D5 okay it's fine
it's fine
fine all right here we
go okay he played really badly
here
why do I always lose to
him why can I
say
again oh
one
no what am I
doing
and we got him
there I need a win I need a win come on
don't get me against Taro Carl
demitry no way no
way I need him to play Bishop I need a
gift
escaping I'm
losing oh we Blended his Ro
come on come on resign resign come on
girl oh no wait here
okay didar like win two in this man that
I won one we got him quickly quickly I'm
in
first
I we got the
win let's go I won with 10 seconds left
I was dead lost I didn't even have to
rush
yeah I just needed the luck of the the
luck of the
mates the the critical game I think was
the game I got luckiest was this one
this was just a gift from the heavens
this was an actual gift from the heavens
I think Magnus Magnus
withdrew this is an actual gift from the
heavens but it's so nice to in a bull
braw when Magnus and hikaro are
playing
yeah the thing is that the pairings are
completely and then this game obviously
was was insane and then the last game I
mean I was just getting crushed by this
by this 2400 because I was trying so
hard to M him quickly to get another
game in butaro lost his
streak and then I almost bled a
Perpetual I think I still would have won
even with a draw believe it or not but I
I realized I could move my rook and get
my king some
squares that was definitely one of the
craziest finals um bullet braw finals
I've had I had one where I beat hikaro
in like a critical game with 15 minutes
left but never that I lost to him and
then still passed him with you know
almost no time left on the clock and
then I lost the next game
too Yar blundered a crazy Rook stalemate
let's see I'm curious what was his what
was his critical draw oh it was this
one yeah I'm telling this Carill cluckin
guy is just always 2800 but he's he's
really
strong
oh well thank you barter
T yeah I completely I completely folded
against iaro this this
time GNA have to figure out what um what
went wrong in those games but still oh
my
gosh well that made my today thank you
thank you everybody for supporting and
Keeping the Faith this was a very up and
down bullet braw but we keep our streak
going um yeah congrats to everybody else
who played and I will be back very soon
thanks folks for supporting really
appreciate
it and uh I'll see see y'all
[Music]
later